Football is dividing America
in half.
Half of this country wants to
talk about issues
that are taking place
outside of the field.
Things like race, inequality,
and police brutality.
Things that affect
everyday Americans.
And half the country just wants
to talk about flags,
uncomplicated,
two-dimensional flags.
Because what President Trump
is saying,
and what these protesters don't
seem to get, is that America
is actually more important
than Americans.
It's America first,
and, to finish that thought,
Americans second.
-Now... Ameri...
-(applause)
Listen up, listen up.
Americans are complicated,
with issues and problems
and allegations
of systemic racism.
These are things
that make me sad.
America, on the other hand
is unimpeachable.
It's flawless, and easy to find
on a map.
That makes me happy.
America is coleslaw, hot dogs,
monster trucks and football.
The idea of America
is what needs protecting.
That flag has been perfect
ever since Betsy Ross
sewed those 50 stars onto it
back in 1770-something.
She knew that America never
needed to change.
It just needed to be protected.
And I like to think that when
those New England Patriots
took the field against those
regular England redcoats,
none of them were kneeling.
But now, America is facing
an enemy even scarier
than a malnourished Brit
with a musket: Americans.
And we here at The Opposition
feel that we are the first line
of defense for you people
of America
against Americans
protesting America.
So here are some effective ways
to reclaim football
and make it uncomplicated
and enjoyable.
Oppo-Tip one:
Just watch the games in reverse.
That way, players are so moved
by the national anthem
that they stand up and run
backwards into the locker-room.
Also, most of the game is just
a bunch of players hugging
and then jumping away from each
other into organized formations.
Oppo-Tip number two:
We created this great
photo filter
over at the Shopposition
that gives kneeling players
legs.
Your favorite players may seem
a little shorter,
but at least those jacked
Billbos will respect the flag.
-Now...
-(laughter)
Oppo-Tip three.
Forget football, it's ruined.
We need a new, even more
American sport.
A sport that won't waste
players' legs kneeling.
In fact,
it will get them standing
and using their legs
at all times.
Also, ditch the pads
and helmets.
Americans, we aren't afraid of
a little rough and tumble.
Plus, a football
has two pointy ends,
and after this whole debacle,
I'm sick and tired of points.
Make that ball round.
Now, yes.
There's a football that
Americans can get behind.
It's gonna be huge.